so beyond this spider-verse is now
officially my most anticipated movie due
to debutant 2024 I'm really excited to
see the culmination of the spider-verse
trilogy and also all the things that we
could be getting in the future this
video is going to be one big you don't
do time do you time time
to die and we'll be talking about what
we think could happen in the film and
where it could lead now obviously heavy
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then I'll
recommend you check out now if you enjoy
the video please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day by the
way a huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into our Theory zombie on
the spider verse my friend runs a
channel called heavy spoilers where he
explains breakdowns etc etc oh no way he
would have killed me if I didn't wear
this into this interview
thank you
now before talking about it I think we
have to go into what happened at the end
of across the spider-verse refusing to
allow his dad to die miles raced across
Nueva York which is where he was chased
by the entire spider Society luring them
away from their base he was able to
return back there and use one of their
devices to send him back to his reality
or so he thought turns out that because
the spider that bit him was from Another
Universe had put DNA from it 42 in him
which had then got on to replace his own
this meant that the machine registered
him as being from that universe and thus
it sent him back there instead in this
reality because the spider had been
plucked from it it had never been miles
there and thus the one on this Earth had
a vastly different time because miles
never went against his uncle Aaron he
instead ended up siding with him man we
saw that he'd become this universe as
Prowler strapping him to a punching bag
just like PW Parker he started to
question what was going on with Miles
and his home reality interested in his
dad still being alive we ended with
asking why he should let miles go now he
actually end with Miles putting his
fingers to the chains of the punching
bag and then starting to rev up his
special Venom Powers I think come the
next film that we will likely see him
escape the bag and then we'll watch his
mile test out run the pralar variant
across this alternate Earth the problem
he has right now is that he's got
nowhere to get back home and this is due
to the bands for the Multiverse now no
longer being on him which when I think
about it I don't even think he had
access to he had the guest pass so he's
never had the ability to jump into other
universes now the only way he got into
Earth 42 was that he used that machine
and thus there's no way for him to exit
this reality that's where things
spider-gwen's gonna come in and after
rounding up all the other spider people
from the first film she's now got the
technology to travel across the
Multiverse because of the homemade
device Hobie made hair he's there with
her too alongside spider bite and
Spider-Man India who've now formed this
new crew now I think that they'll
possibly head out looking for Miles
which is when they'll discover that he's
on Earth body too I don't think that
this will be the end of parallel miles
either and I think he might travel
across to Martha's Universe through
getting one of the devices from the
other spiders his interests seem to Peak
with the mention that Jefferson's still
alive and he might want to live the life
that he never got to have automatically
this is something that we've seen lace
out all the antagonists that have
appeared in the franchise so far Kingpin
wanted to use the collider to pull a
family across from Another Universe and
Miguel traveled into an alternate
reality so that he could go on and have
one I can't see this being reflected in
parallel miles too and it might make the
main miles realize just how lucky he is
he has kind of taken his family for
granted at this point and I think that's
seeing what another version of him would
give to be with them will show what he
needs to do a problem Isles going into
this reality could very much destroy it
and this would be similar to what
happened with Miguel therefore it's of
the utmost importance that they don't
allow this to happen and I think that
the prowler miles is going to be a very
big villain now the destruction of the
reality is something that the spots
after two as he wants to take everything
miles has across the spider-verse we
watch as he drops into miles reality
back home in order to set off a chain of
events that will likely kill Jefferson
in the vision he shows miles we see
hints of this with Jefferson trying to
save a child which is when he's killed
by debris this is something that's
classed as a Canon event and it would
also make this spot the Nemesis that he
wants to be now on this reality we also
know that Miguel and Co are waiting
there for Miles however with the arrival
of the spot there they're gonna be left
with two choices the more I think about
it with them it's kind of a lose-lose
situation as is only two things that
they can now do the first is that they
actually let the spot Go and Kill
Jefferson because that's what's meant to
happen when we look at the cannon now
the conflict here comes from the fact
that they are supposed to be stopping
big bad guys like this and with the spot
becoming even more powerful he's no
longer just civilian of the week so you
think that they'd be desperate to take
him out but they're almost gonna have to
let it play out so that he can kill
Jefferson however this could also make
him even a more powerful and push him to
becoming a far more Supreme Force you
see he wants to take everything from
Miles which likely includes destroying
this reality and despite a society
they're meant to be protecting universes
on the other side of this if they step
in and stop him this is gonna cause a
Canon event to be disrupted and it's
gonna lead to the destruction of this
reality so they don't really have a
choice in all honesty and they're sort
of in a moral quandary now to me
stopping the spot is far more important
than letting Jefferson die this spot is
someone who could go across the
Multiverse and destroy everything there
or as we've seen that the Canon events
can be disrupted and saved if the
society act fast enough when the black
hole appeared in mumbatin they set up
devices to handle it and thus there are
ways that they can stabilize things
Gwen's reality didn't implode when her
father gave up the badge either and this
means that he won't die in the line of
duty so there are certain things that
can be changed they just have to make
the right choice with it now they might
make miles make the tough choices well
and cause the death of his father so
that everything can work out that's
pretty dark but it's something that's
happened in a similar story that I won't
spoil in case it turns Up Down the Line
I'll talk about it soonish but yeah I
have a feeling something like that might
be happening soon and I'd just rather
avoid it talk to you talk to you about
in two weeks I'm nice like that now as
for how the entire Trilogy ends I
actually think that we might see a segue
from here into a live-action version of
the character this movie slowly started
introducing live action elements and we
saw this in Miss Chen and also Donald
Glover now I think it would be stupid
for Sony to do the live action version
they've just announced by starting
things from square one we already have a
miles that we love and bring the
character across from this I think would
work so well if you've read Secret Wars
and you know that culminates with
characters like miles being brought
across from the ultimate version and
they then show up in the 616 we can have
this acting as his origin story and just
hit the ground running when we get into
that makes sense as we've also seen live
action Donald Glover appearing as the
prowler in the MCU we know that the snap
has happened and there's been a big
five-year time Jump in these five years
I could easily see Aaron becoming the
prowler and the one we see here my B
from the MCU however he did mention his
nephew in Spider-Man homecoming so maybe
they wouldn't be able to just bring him
right over but I'd love to see it and
that that's why this is just you time
few times it might not happening a huge
hit out as well to just watching nine on
dial92 on our ending explained video
dropped a theory saying they think the
Aaron we met here might be the one who
saves Jefferson when you think about it
his brother was killed and you can
imagine that he'd want to write this
wrong in another reality knowing that
he's in danger might also be what pushes
him to help miles and I think the
character is going to turn in beyond the
spider verse at the punching bag
interaction we saw miles say to Aaron
that he knows he doesn't want to be the
prowler and that he can sense good in
him this is shut down though when he
reveals that he's not but I still think
there's this side of him that can change
it over that idea takes a lot of focus
in the conversation and I think that he
might also redeem himself in the
upcoming film sure he didn't kill miles
at the kingpin's request but he didn't
really get the chance to change due to
him being killed shortly after I think
that would work really well in the film
and it would be a nice way for him and
his brother to also patch things up they
didn't really get the chance to win that
original spider-verse movie and knowing
that both lost that Brothers I think
that they're going to come together and
kind of redeem themselves to each other
now moving on to another character
something about Miguel just doesn't sit
right with me he came across as brutal
and almost verging on the Thanos Style
by doing the worst things possible for
the greater good now when he's
introduced by Gwen we hear how he's
almost like a vampire and he even has
fangs Miguel did indeed gain fangs in
the comics and what looks like claws
after his experiments were sabotaged so
yeah there is a whole thing in the
comics that explains why he looks like a
vampire but there's also another group
that has a connection to the
spider-verse stories that I think could
be linked in yep if you've read them
then you know who I'm talking about and
this is the creepy spider Slayers known
as the inheritors this group feed on
totems which are animal human hybrids
more specifically all the spider terms
basically in case you don't know them
they go around the Multiverse and try to
kill all the other spider people now
while the vampire teeth and Claws things
could be part of his origin like the
comics and Gwen just hyping him up let's
use our web fluid to reach further than
Spidey holding a bridge together what if
Miguel O'Hara isn't actually Miguel
O'Hara and he's in fact a character
known as the master Weaver the
inheritors have been suspiciously not
involved in the spider-verse movies thus
far and Miguel himself said he went to a
world where a version of him had died
what if he's actually an inheritor
working to bring all the spiders
together so that his clan can chow down
on them like it's a spider Buffet Miguel
seems particularly ruthless in this
movie and he's also built a spider
device that spins which looks like a web
that sends you back home this is
something that's linked in with the
master Weaver and though it might be
reaching I think there are some
connections here the master weave itself
was a title given to the person who
maintains the web of life and Destiny
which is a model of the entire
Multiverse when explaining the Canon
events a web was spun around and it
looked like the MCU Multiverse sacred
timeline this could be a manifestation
of the Web of Life in Destiny but it
seems curious that Miguel knows so much
about this spider Multiverse the
inheritors in the past took control of
the master Weaver and used to hunt all
the spider totems so this could be how
he managed to gain this knowledge after
the inheritors were defeated by the
spider Army and ostracized member of the
inheriter's name Khan became the master
Weaver and I think it would be a hell of
a Twist to reveal that this is actually
Miguel saying that though they could
make the character someone like Merlin
and that's a pretty big Theory time to
close the video off with massive shout
outs to our editor map for noticing that
and the guy he sold me on the idea that
it couldn't fact be him anyway let us
know your thoughts in the comment
section below and if you're as hyped as
I am for Beyond this spider verse you
want to support the channel for as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below and as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos every week you also have our
merch store over at xeroedition.com
which sells lots of nerdy and spy
t-shirts hats and more we just launched
a secret Invasion slash Pulp Fiction
inspired t-shirt so if you want to head
over there and help us out then the
links in the description now if you want
some Elves to watch we have a
spider-verse video on screen right now
so definitely head over there right
after this other way huge thank you for
singing through the video I've been poor
and I'll see you next time take care
peace